[Music]
listen
this sound is the first evidence of the
big bang
and this is a story of two radio
astronomers who discovered proof of the
beginning of everything
this is the horn reflector antenna at
bell laboratories robert can you tell us
what this thing does it receives radio
waves coming from the direction it's
pointed to
and funnels them into a receiver that's
robert wilson radio astronomer in the
early 60s he and his colleague arno
penzias were tasked with measuring the
brightness of the sky using the horn
reflector antenna but no matter where
they pointed it the antenna read a much
larger signal than the pair expected our
immediate reaction was that there must
be something wrong with our system
they thought it might be interference
from the horn itself or new york city or
even some pigeons living in the horn you
know we thought about a collection of
ordinary sources that are in the very
distance that just didn't seem to be
possible so they reached out to a group
of researchers at princeton university
led by astrophysicist robert dickey who
had been scouring the sky unsuccessfully
for evidence of the big bang arnold
called and
dickie picked up the phone
and they started hearing things like
atmospheric radiation sky brightness
all the things that they were working on
dickie put the phone down and said boys
we've been scooped
robert and arno had measured what dicky
and his team were searching for the
elusive cosmic microwave background
radiation
he thought about a big bang source of
the universe
realized that it would be very hot and
therefore full of radiation
and as the universe expanded that
radiation would simply cool
and whereas it was extremely hot to
start with by now it would simply be
microwaves now it's so cold that it
would just be radio waves
and this nut pigeons or the noisy city
was exactly what had been causing
headaches for robert wilson and arno
penzias the two groups of researchers
from bell labs and princeton each wrote
complementary research papers with their
findings they wrote one about the theory
we wrote one about our measurement and
we published them i think unlike many
changes that occur in science
there really was a paradigm shift with
very little push back
it was huge there was no evidence of a
new theory for the beginning of the
entire universe over a decade later
robert wilson and arno penzias were
awarded the 1978 nobel prize in physics
how'd that feel robert
felt pretty strange to win the nobel
prize i didn't feel comfortable being on
the same list with einstein but despite
robert's humility there's no doubt the
significance of the discovery it gives
us our earliest picture of the universe
from which we can extrapolate back to
very early times
as one of the centerpieces of cosmology
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we all know that
the american flag has endured in its
many forms as the ultimate symbol of
freedom justice in the american way but
did you know that our nation's flag
was designed by a high school student
from ohio
according to legend the original
american flag from 1776 was sewn by a
lady named betsy ross it had 13 stars in
a circle representing america's original
13 states as more states joined the
union people kept adding more stars to
the flag so by 1958 the us flag had a
total of 48 stars for the 48 states of
that time which brings us to our high
school student robert heft
robert's history teacher gave his
students an open-ended assignment make a
project illustrating your interest in
american history it could be anything
so robert who was jazzed about hearing
that alaska and hawaii were going to
become states caught up an old 48 state
flag in his grandparent's basement and
designed his own vision for a 50-state
flag
when he turned in his final assignment
robert's teacher said anyone can make a
flag and it's got the wrong number of
stars the grade came back a b-minus
robert tried to explain his idea to his
teacher who replied i'll change your
grade when your flag is accepted by the
us congress
game on
robert wrote 21 letters and called the
white house 18 times until one day in
1960 robert's phone rang
[Music]
hello hello robert it was president
eisenhower with news that robert's 50
state flag design had actually been
chosen as the new official flag of the
united states
the president invited robert to
washington where he saw his american
flag fly for the first time on july 4th
1960.
[Applause]
since then robert's 50 state flag has
remained unmatched as the quintessential
symbol of america but i know what you're
thinking whatever happened to that
b-minus
robert's teacher honored his promise and
changed the grade to an
[Music]
remember egg island the 90s kids show on
nick jr featuring a fun family and a
pollywog named bingabia
well
it's a real place
kind of
i'm natalie days and i played miss
natalie on delegate island my name is
ron days and i served as a dad
show me how old you are shane bye
there is no real place named galaga
island except on tv
it is based on the galagic culture which
was passed on by enslaved west africans
who were brought to this country
galagici culture was born out of several
african cultures and languages brought
here by enslaved people
everything from cuisines and traditional
practices have been maintained through
generations of settlement in coastal
villages in georgia and the carolinas
i am telegi and proud of it it's
important to me to make sure that
gulagiji culture is preserved because
it's a very important factor of american
cultural heritage
when natalie and ron got the opportunity
to present their culture on tv they
jumped at the chance by the time we met
the woman who became the executive
producer we had been traveling around
the country doing stories and songs of
gullah culture that's what we did
in the beginning we didn't know that it
was so significant there had never been
a show like that before we wanted a show
where our children could see themselves
we actually ended up with a show where
everybody could see themselves in us
before we go would you guys mind seeing
us out
now we get asked a lot
come and let's play together in the
bright sunny weather
[Music]
fondue it's this thing we do with cheese
we melt it we dip it we eat it in the
70s it became super popular but that
didn't just happen by chance there was
an ominous force behind it a real life
cheese cartel
a hundred years ago cheese was a hot
commodity in switzerland it was exported
at high volumes and played a major role
in the swiss economy but that all
changed after world war one european
countries devastated by the war could no
longer afford to buy expensive imported
cheese which was bad news for
switzerland so the government stepped in
and they formed the cheese union
basically it was a cartel and it worked
like this the first thing they did was
force every dairy farmer and cheese
monger to fix the price of cheese
eliminating competition meaning everyone
could stay in the game the cheese cartel
also told them exactly how much cheese
to make and limited the varieties so
instead of making thousands of different
kinds of cheese they only made seven and
it worked the cartel controlled the
cheese supply for decades
by the 70s they got greedy and wanted to
expand their cheese racket globally so
they introduced the world to a dish
already popular in the freezing cold
alps fondue by marketing cheese for
fondue the cartel was able to sell more
i mean think about it it takes a lot and
i mean a lot of cheese to fill a pot but
as with most cartels things got shady
money went missing people went to jail
and by the 1990s the swiss cheese union
was dismantled so there you have it the
reason we know and love fondue is
because of a shady government program
that convinced the world to consume
massive amounts of melted cheese
[Music]
peace love and rock and roll it's the
hippie creed along with some flower
power and some crunchy granola and we
call hippies crunchy granola because of
well
granola
[Music]
the link between the people the culture
and the granola it started in 1969 at
woodstock
organizers estimated that 200 000
fun-loving people would build a small
town of bethlehem new york for the
three-day historic festival but the
number of attending doubled and the next
thing they knew there were over 400 000
people camping out which led to
shortages food shortages and well that
left the munchies craving free loving
hippies a little hangry
this is where the savior hugh romney
came in hugh and his commune hog farm
were hired to help organizers run the
festival upon seeing the food shortage
they stepped in to help they rounded up
a group of volunteers hit the streets
and came back with you guessed it
granola
members of hog farm filled tons of cups
and hugh took the stage and announced
there would be breakfast in bed for 400
000
the hippies ate it up and for many it
was their first introduction to the
crunchy stuff and so there you have it
the original bond between crunchy
granola and hippies was formed by
granola at the one and only woodstock
music festival
[Music]
you